et avec Léa Salamé nous recevons ce
matin un ingénieur professeur à l'École
des Mines présidents du Fing tank the
shift project son expertise son public
nombreux et fervents ont fait de le dire
de lui qu'il était la rockstar de la
transition énergétique ça le fait déjà
marée vos questions amis auditeurs au 01
45 24 7000 et sur l'application FRANCE
INTER Jean-Marc Jancovici bonjour
bonjour et merci d'être à notre micro
avant de démarrer une rockstar ça
remplit le Parc des Princes moi je
remplis un emphys n'avoir oui mais avec
les réseaux sociaux
ça fait un milliard de vues moi une
vidéo ça fait un million de nuit
donc on y est on a fait l'explication
texte on va analyser avec vous
évidemment le bilan de la COP 27 la
feuille de route du gouvernement pour la
écologique la question de la sobriété
mais un mot tiens sur nous et vous pour
commencer nous les journalistes vous
avez longtemps testé contre les médias
en disant que sur tous ces sujets on
n'était pas au niveau maintenant on ne
peut plus allumer sa télé ou sa radio
ouvrir un journal sans vous voir alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé Jean-Marc Jancovici est-ce
que vous avez pris votre bâton de
pèlerin ou est-ce que vous aimez voilà
qu'on est moins con et que la prise de
conscience a progressé tout de même dans
les médias et que le traitement de ces
sujets là est aujourd'hui tout de même
de meilleure qualité et aussi de plus
grande ampleur alors on peut très bien
être en progression tout en étant pas
encore là où on devrait
les deux sont pas impossibles donc c'est
clair oui les médias ont quand même
bougé par rapport il y a 10 ans ça c'est
très clair mais par contre il y a
énormément de choses qui se passent dans
les médias et entre être invité quelque
part et avoir partout et tout le temps
un traitement de l'information qui soit
satisfaisant il y a une différence et
puis par ailleurs je me considère pas
enfin je considère pas que le fait qu'on
m'invite comme étant le thermomètre
majeur du fait que les médias racontent
des bêtises ou pas de bêtises si
j'essaye de synthétiser un peu ma
position sur les médias je trouve que le
grand n'importe quoi il s'est déplacé
c'est à dire qu'il y a 10 ans le grand
n'importe quoi il était encore sur la
définition des problèmes alors
aujourd'hui il y a un problème qui reste
encore très mal défini dans les médias
c'est le problème qu'on a coutume
d'appeler sous le nom picoy c'est-à-dire
la limitation géologique et non pas pour
des raisons climatiques de
l'approvisionnement en pétrole et en gaz
ça c'est encore un comment dire quelque
chose qui passe totalement sous l'écran
pas de problème c'est à dire que
maintenant on entend beaucoup de bruit
sur l'avion à hydrogène qui va permettre
de sauver l'aviation commerciale la
voiture électrique qui va permettre
d'avoir 1,2 milliards de véhicules
particulier d'une tonne et demie dans le
monde etc donc en gros on exagère où on
rend excessivement simple la solution au
problème
on va en parler là pour le coup c'est
pas seulement les médias c'est notamment
la première ministre Elisabeth borne
alors pour le coup
prend le double exemple
j'insiste sur le fait que c'est pas
France Inter c'est d'une manière
générale on a compris on vous fait
sourire aussi
et là du coup on voit énormément de
d'informations qui sont repris sans
hauteur de vue sans mise en perspective
et qui donne l'illusion que le problème
va être très facile à mettre sous
contrôle
venons-en maintenant à la COP 27 un
accord a été salué un échec déploré
également on va commencer par l'accord
de 196 pays qui ont décidé de créer un
fond pour les pertes c'est dommages afin
d'aider financièrement les pays en
développement particulièrement
vulnérable à faire face aux dégâts
irréversibles causés par le
réchauffement climatique les pays du Sud
portaient cette revendication les pays
du Nord ruschini à l'affaire ils ont
finalement signé est-ce que ça ça va
dans le bon sens alors la clause de
perte des dommages la première fois que
j'en ai entendu parler comme étant
quelque chose sur lequel le pays se
mettait d'accord c'était à Copenhague en
2009 vous dites c'était la meilleure
Cope d'ailleurs oui absolument c'était
la meilleure Coop parce que c'est la
seule qui a pas suivi le processus au
new-y viens des cops c'est la seule où
il y a eu des vrais décisions et en
particulier l'objectif politique des
sous les deux degrés date de Copenhague
c'est à ce moment-là que les États se
sont mis d'accord sur cet objectif
le je vous avoue ne pas avoir regardé
dans les détails ce que Charm el shake
avait amené par rapport au corps
précédentes sur la clause de pertes et
dommages enfin sur le fond de perte des
dommages donc je sais pas quels sont les
avancées techniques qui ont eu lieu par
contre ce que je sais c'est que le
principe même il est acté depuis
longtemps
donc un parallèle que je pense souvent
pour désigner ce qui se passe dans une
coop c'est imaginons que vous ayez un
immeuble dans lequel vous avez 200
copropriétaires
chaque copropriété dispose d'une voix
que il est le penthouse des derniers
étages ou un placard à balai au sous-sol
vous avez un énorme dégât des eaux qui
suppose de tout refaire dans l'immeuble
chaque copropriétaire doit payer par
contre au prorata de sa surface et vous
démarrez la Réunion le matin sans syndic
sans programme de travaux 100 personnes
qui arrivent avec un projet de
résolution chacun arrive en disant voilà
ce que je pense qu'il devrait faire il
faut se mettre à l'unanimité d'accord le
temps d'une journée donc vous dites en
fait les efforts il faut les faire au
niveau national
alors c'est utile parce qu'on en parle
voilà donc ça sert à en parler il ne
faut rien en attendre d'autre de mon
point de vue sauf un peu de lissage
éventuellement entre pays qui sont déjà
d'accord pour avancer de façon
importante Jean-Marc jeancovici
aujourd'hui les pays occidentaux et leur
gouvernement ont peur de manquer
d'énergie vous le savez pour se chauffer
on parle de de coupure d'électricité
peut-être en janvier en France on rouvre
les centrales à charbon on crée des
terminaux métaniers la crise énergétique
la guerre en Ukraine le retour de
l'inflation ne font-ils pas
ralentir ou en tout cas passer la lutte
contre la jument climatique au second
plan alors ça va un peu servir la lutte
contre le changement climatique cette
affaire là parce que si on manque de gaz
on aimait moins une CO2 si on manque de
pétrole on est même moins une CO2 par la
force des choses et en fait ça regroupe
avec ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur
l'approvisionnement qui est limité par
la géologie
c'est évident que les émissions de CO2
peuvent pas croître un défiment ça
n'existe pas sur une planète finie elle
ne peut pas m'arrêter indéfiniment
constante ça n'existe pas plus sur une
planète finie donc la seule question
c'est de savoir qu'est-ce qu'il est fera
baisser un jour est-ce que c'est notre
volonté ou est-ce que c'est des
événements externes comme ceux que vous
venez d'évoquer ou d'autres on peut
avoir comme dans le CUP une météorite on
peut avoir une pandémie on peut avoir un
effondrement économique on peut avoir
enfin tout un tas de trucs et si c'est
pas là ça sera l'autre et là on est en
train d'expérimenter un peu
malheureusement l'autre il faut bien
voir que Poutine en fait il ne fait
qu'accélérer l'histoire je le redis la
production mondiale de pétrole
conventionnelle le pic c'était 2008 et
la production mondiale de pétrole tout
compris y compris le pétrole de schiste
et s'habitue mieux il est pas possible
que ça a été 2018 c'est un peu trop tôt
pour le dire maintenant mais il est
possible que ça a été 2018 donc de toute
façon on va devoir faire avec moi et on
a tellement perdu de temps à ne pas
comprendre que on a les de toute façon
faire avec moi que au moment où on est
surpris par le moins involontaire qui
arrive bah à ce moment on répond dans le
désordre donc effectivement on se dit
bah tiens et on va avoir un problème
avec le système électrique bah oui mais
enfin ces trucs là ça se gère avec des
décennies d'anticipation on va avoir un
problème avec le système de transport
mais enfin on est passé de 2 à 40
millions de véhicules particuliers entre
1945 et aujourd'hui et un jour on se dit
ah ben tiens il va falloir qu'on chante
mais on va pas changer ça en une semaine
donc en fait c'est ça notre problème
c'est que on n'arrive pas à raisonner
sur les bons horizons de temps pour
plein de raisons mais c'est donc un jour
on se retrouve surpris Léa on disait un
mot venant à la France la première
ministre Elisabeth borne a présenté la
semaine dernière sa stratégie en matière
de politique énergétique elle a décliné
trois leviers sobriété parce que la
meilleure énergie c'est celle qu'on ne
consomme pas
la production des carbonées grâce aux
nucléaire et au renouvelable et enfin
l'innovation avec l'hydrogène que
pensez-vous de cette feuille de route
est-ce que les bons mots sont là alors
les bons morceaux là sauf que quand il
s'agit de passer aux actes les bons
actes sont pas nécessairement là je vais
donner un exemple de sobriété qui est un
exemple qui est pas qui porte pas sur
l'essentiel de la consommation de
pétrole dans ce pays mais qui est le 110
sur autoroute alors justement
sauf à ce que j'ai été très mal informé
je comprends que notre première ministre
n'y est pas très favorable or c'est une
mesure de sobriété et non seulement
c'est une mesure de sobriété mais c'est
une mesure de sobriété à laquelle sauf à
ce que je sois également très mal
informé la majorité de la population est
désormais favorable donc je comprends
pas ce qu'elle fait
je vais vous donner un autre exemple sur
les mesures de sobriété il y a un sujet
sur la température dans les logements
alors ça en fait ça fait depuis les
chocs pétroliers que on a normalement
une obligation réglementaire en France
de limiter la température à 19 degrés
vous avez énormément de bâtiments dans
lesquels c'est pas le cas alors bon
certes c'est une mesure de sobriété on
peut dire c'est pas très sympathique
parce que il faut enfin bon 19 degrés
c'est quand même pas la mort degrés
depuis toujours chez vous probablement
un peu moins
vous cailler je mets un pull un col
roulé je mange des soupes non je
plaisante donc là voilà donc la question
de la sobriété c'est que pour que ce
soit efficace il faut pas que ça reste
un mot à un moment il faut parler
mesures concrètes et il faut parler
impact quantifié des mesures concrètes
mais quand même quand vous regardez les
chiffres de RTI qui montre que la
tendance est à la baisse de la
consommation le dernier mois il y a
quand même une prise de conscience et
des actes aussi on le RTE dit que la
consommation d'électricité a baissé de
6,5% de moyenne par rapport à la période
2014-2019 vous saluez quand même ça
alors
climatiques parce qu'on a eu un mois
d'octobre extrêmement doux et nous avons
extrêmement doux ou pas parce que c'est
ça peut être la première raison je vous
avoue ne pas avoir regardé cette
déclaration mais la première chose à
laquelle je pense c'est ça
Elisabeth borne a déclaré par ailleurs
que la transition énergétique va de pair
avec la croissance et la création
d'emplois elle va accompagner la
réindustrialisation et permettre
l'émergence de secteurs et de filières
d'avenir et transition énergétique et
croissance croissance verte vous êtes
d'accord ou c'est un mythe je pense que
c'est un mythe alors Elisabeth borne
elle fait un métier comme tous les
politiques qui consistent à dire que
tout est sous contrôle donc tout est
sous contrôle ça veut dire que on va à
la fois avoir la croissance économique
parce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour l'État pas de croissance économique
ça veut dire des recettes fiscales qui
baissent et ça veut dire le spectre du
chômage
donc en fait sur le fond c'est pas
tellement la croissance c'est le fait
que chômage est pas de recette ça c'est
quelque chose pour lequel l'État n'est
pas prêt parce qu'il y a pas de plan B
pour ce genre de pour ce genre de
situation
quand on regarde ce qui a fait la
croissance économique des deux derniers
siècles c'est essentiellement l'air des
machines donc l'air de l'énergie en fait
l'énergie renouvelable c'était la
totalité de l'énergie qu'on utilisait il
y a deux siècles et demi et la
civilisation industrielle a consisté à
sortir des énergies redables et pas du
tout il est rentré et là on y retourne
aux énergies renouvelables alors oui
mais est-ce qu'on va garder la
civilisation industrielle
ce dont on a fait la preuve pour parler
des énergies renouvelables en
particulier de l'éolien du soleil parce
qu'en général c'est ça qu'on a en tête
quand on parle d'énergie renouvelable ce
dont on a fait la preuve sur les 20
dernières années c'est qu'on savait
fabriquer plus d'éoliennes et de
panneaux solaires dans un monde qui par
ailleurs a doublé sa consommation de
charbon et augmenter de 50% sa
consommation d'énergie fossiles donc en
fait dans un monde mondialisé où c'est
très facile de mettre en France le
résultat de l'exploitation des
minailleurs de la pétrochimie ailleurs
et des portes-conteneurs partout dans le
monde on a fait la démonstration que
dans ce contexte là on savait installer
des éoliennes et les panneaux solaires
mais est-ce qu'on saura toujours le
faire dans un contexte dans lequel il y
a plus de mondialisation plus de
porte-conteneurs et plus de camions
pas sûr donc on voit bien que les
énergies renouvelables il y a trois
siècles c'est pas les machines
technologiques qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
c'est rien à voir Jean-Marc jungkovici
elle est renouvelable et il y a le
nucléaire la France se félicitait sur le
nucléaire c'était la notre grande fierté
on était indépendant on était souverain
grâce au nucléaire et aujourd'hui et
Dominique se le rappeler dans son édito
tout à l'heure seul 32% seul 32 des 56
réacteurs nucléaires français
fonctionnent qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
sur le nucléaire c'est un problème de
moyen c'est un problème chez EDF c'est
un problème de volonté politique comment
on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec cette
crise où on a 32 réacteurs seulement qui
marchent sur cette félicité sur le
nucléaire dans ce pays c'est oublier un
peu vite que sur cette antenne et
quelques autres ont du même groupe on
n'a pas vraiment dit du bien du
nucléaire pendant assez longtemps donc
non on sait pas vraiment félicité du
nucléaire en fait la colonne non la
coloration dans le débat public sur le
nucléaire c'est 20 dernières années
c'est baladé plutôt quelque part entre
bon on en a mais faut pas le dire trop
fort jusqu'à ça serait quand même bien
qu'on en est pas alors justement
pourquoi on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec
tous ces réacteurs en panne qui
qu'est-ce qui se passe quoi est-ce que
ça vous inquiète alors non ça m'inquiète
pas spécialement parce que dans le en
fait il y a pas que des réacteurs en
panne il y a également des réacteurs qui
ont été en décalage de maintenant c'est
parce que on est dans la suite du covid
où il y a eu à cause du covid des
perturbations dans la possibilité de
maintien des réacteurs et une diminution
de la de leur production donc il y a
aussi de l'uranium qui est resté enfin
des assemblages qui sont restés plus
longtemps dans les dans les réacteurs
parce que il n'était pas question de les
sortir avant que tout l'uranium ait été
consommé après il y a également eu le
défaut de la corrosion sous contrainte
voilà ça c'est une mauvaise surprise
c'est pas un truc très grave sur le fond
tout simplement ça immobilise les
réacteurs le temps qu'on fasse la
réparation c'est ça le c'est ça le sujet
est-ce que dans ce pays on s'est donné
toutes les chances j'ai envie de dire
d'avoir un nucléaire qui fonctionne bien
non on sait pas donner toutes les
chances parce que quand vous avez un
actionnaire c'est le pouvoir politique
qui dit du mal publiquement assez
souvent de ce que fait l'opérateur dont
il a la charge vous vous retrouvez
l'intérieur de l'opérateur avec des
situations qui sont un peu compliquées
et dans la filière avec des situations
un peu compliquées imaginons que vous
soyez un chaudronnier travaillant pour
la filière nucléaire oui Léa Salamé
incorporités et donc vous entendez le
pouvoir politique dire quand même le
nucléaire c'est pas terrible on va
arrêter vous avez envie vous de
continuer à vendre à cette filière vous
dites c'est un secteur où je suis sûr de
garder mes clients etc donc pour vous ça
a été le ça a été le discours politique
ça a été je dis pas que c'est la seule
raison mais je dis que fatalement il y a
contribué bien sûr de faire mes 14
réacteurs de faire mes fashion même si
on va pas le faire le discours là-dessus
et de quelque chose qui crée de
l'incertitude et quand vous créez de
l'incertitude dans une filière
économique de long terme en général ça
n'améliore pas les choses allez beaucoup
de questions standard on y va tout de
suite Stéphane bonjour
bonjour vous nous dites faire partie
d'extinction rébellion on vous écoute
un petit groupe dans les Hautes-Alpes
comme ça se multiplie un peu de partout
il y a pas qu'un section réveillon il y
a plein de groupes qui se soulève parce
que ça fait trop longtemps trop trop
longtemps qu'on parle qu'on parle qu'on
parle il se passe rien donc à un moment
faut mettre un peu les mains dans le
cambouis et un peu aller dans l'action
un peu radical alors
la question c'était comme pensait
monsieur Jean-Côme ici il y a une groupe
qui s'appelle scientifique en rébellion
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à se
poser des les bonnes questions me
semble-t-il puisque depuis 1974 et René
Dumont on sait très bien qu'en
continuant la même direction mais rien
ne change on vous avait pu voir tourner
sur le net la courbe des émissions de
CO2 liées au nombre de cops et on voit
que non et rien ne change donc à un
moment voilà je voulais voir un peu son
point de vue sur ce genre d'action comme
on a vu le à de nombreux endroits oui
notamment dans les musées ces dernières
semaines merci Stéphane pour cette
question Jean-Marc Jancovici sur ces
nouvelles formes de militantisme en fait
c'est quelque chose qui existe depuis
quand même assez longtemps la
manifestation publique est un truc qui
existe depuis assez longtemps le fait
que dans le cadre de manifestations il
puisse y avoir des gens qui bloquent des
trucs ou etc ça existe depuis assez
longtemps la soupe sur les tableaux vous
en pensez quoi vous bonjour c'est
anecdotique oui
on s'en fout il y a la vitre ou vous
dites le geste et enfin je veux dire
c'est pas la soupe sur le tableau c'est
la soupe sur une vitre bon donc on a
sali une vitre ok bon c'est peut-être
pas la peine d'en faire tout un fromage
même les gens qui bloquent des
autoroutes ou bloque des pistes de Data
d'aéroport etc
vous savez quand une entreprise que je
nommerai pas bloque la circulation des
trains parce que les gens sont en grève
ça met un peu plus le pastis dans la
circulation des gens et on dit il y a
une grève pour vous c'est pas
contre-productif c'est ces actions
est-ce que ça ne parle pas qu'on
convaincu on jugera l'arbre à ses fruits
moi j'ai pas je vais le dire autrement
je considère pas que ce soit quelque
chose de fondamentalement plus immoral
que n'importe quoi d'autre voilà je
prépare sur l'efficacité la moralité
alors on est bien d'accord mais
l'efficacité vous savez encore une fois
on jugera l'arbre à ses fruits c'est
difficile de c'est difficile de savoir
en tout cas ce que je peux dire c'est
que je comprends le sentiment
d'exaspération d'une partie des gens qui
se disent quand même
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que on est
aussi mou
à essayer de faire des choses alors même
que dans une partie de la population
l'opinion comprend bien qu'il va falloir
qu'on change Eco terrorisme
co totalitarisme vous réagissez comment
quand vous entendez des élus c'est des
expressions une expression qui a été
utilisée justement pour la soupe jetée
sur des vitres etc Gérald Darmanin sur
la mobilisation dans les Deux-Sèvres
contre les bassines oui c'est pas du
terrorisme c'est une date c'est pas du
terrorisme c'est une manifestation enfin
je veux dire
terrorisme c'est le Bataclan c'est pas
pareil sur l'application d'Inter le cerf
vous pose la question il commence par
dire qu'il est fan de la rockstar
jankovici mais question sur le nucléaire
comment faire avec la pénurie d'eau et
les sécheresses alors ça c'est pas le
problème majeur auquel on est à faire
avec le nucléaire ce qu'on risque le
pire j'ai envie de dire avec une
centrale nucléaire qui aurait un défaut
d'approvisionnement en eau c'est tout
simplement qu'elle arrête de produire
aujourd'hui une centrale nucléaire qui
fonctionne elle prélève de l'eau dans
une rivière quand la rivière enfin ou un
fleuve quand le fleuve va avoir vraiment
beaucoup de débit en fait elle rejette
l'eau un peu réchauffée et quand le
fleuve a moins de débit en fait une
partie de l'eau est évaporée dans ces
grandes tours de réfrigération là qui
fume et ça ça permet d'utiliser beaucoup
moins d'eau pour le refroidissement mais
la plus grande centrale nucléaire des
États-Unis elle utilise les eaux usées
d'une ville pour se refroidir donc en
fait ce qu'on risque il y a pas de
problème de sûreté avec un défaut d'eau
il y a juste un sujet qu'on peut baisser
la puissance de la centrale parce que il
y a pas assez d'eau pour la fournir
toujours sur l'appli d'Inter Laurent
nous dit qu'il est en train lire le
livre de Greta Thunberg j'ai
l'impression qu'on est loin de pouvoir
rester à un degré 5 de réchauffement
quel est votre avis est-ce qu'il faut
faire le deuil de cet objectif là alors
probablement sauf comète nouvelle peste
ou guerre thermonucléaire oui
aujourd'hui le réchauffement planétaire
il est de l'ordre de 0,2 degrés par
décennies
et même dans un scénario de type accord
de Paris on franchirait les 1,5 degrés
avant 2050 en fait le scénario de type
accord de Paris on nous fait franchir
transitoirement le seuil avant que ça
redescende un peu on peut discuter du
scénario mais donc malheureusement je
pense que l'objectif rester sous un
virgule 5 degrés il est mort l'avion
pour terminer vous dites dans Le
Parisien je suis à titre personnel
favorable à un système communiste riche
ou pauvre vous auriez droit dans toute
votre vie à trois ou quatre vols par
avion dans votre vie dont deux dans la
jeunesse alors
moi ça m'interroge je vais vous dire je
pense que ça intéresse beaucoup de gens
c'est à dire on a le droit disons quatre
vols dans toute notre vie mais on part
il y a beaucoup de gens qui prennent
l'avion pas seulement pour leurs
vacances
ou pour le par loisir il y a beaucoup de
gens qui prennent l'avion aussi pour
rentrer chez eux et voir leurs familles
qui habitent dans un pays qui n'est pas
leur pays d'origine il y a beaucoup de
gens aussi qui voyagent pour le boulot
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites à ces gens
alors je leur dis plusieurs choses la
première c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'avion
c'est 8% du pétrole mondial et l'avion
est né avec le pétrole et mon rat avec
le pétrole d'accord donc il y a pas de
solution technique à l'échelle pour
conserver les quelques milliards je peux
exactement combien il y en a maintenant
de passagers aériens qu'on apparente il
n'y a pas de solution technique à
l'échelle mais comment on fait vous êtes
marocain vous êtes brésilien vous êtes
vos parents je suis désolé de le dire il
verront au moins souvent leurs parents
au brésiliens au Maroc mais c'est pas
moins souvent avec vous ces quatre fois
par an alors ça c'est un autre sujet
c'est une fois que il y a moins d'avion
comment vous le répartissez et là vous
avez deux options à chaque fois que vous
devez gérer moins il y a que deux
options toujours que deux vous le gérez
par les prix vous le gérez par les
quantités et moi ce que je dis c'est que
je trouve que le système où on gère par
les quantités est un système qui est
plus égalitaire que le système on gère
par les prix donc quatre fois dans une
vie entière ça peut être deux ça peut
être 5 j'en sais rien j'ai pas fait les
calculs mais l'idée c'est encore une
fois c'est géré par les quantités plutôt
gérées par les prix mais
philosophiquement c'est quand même
l'idée que chacun reste chez soi en fait
on va pas découvrir d'autres
civilisations on va pas vous savez les
gens qui prennent l'avion pour aller se
mettre dans un hôtel dans une autre
ville où qui se mettent dans un voyage
organisé ou qui vont dans un village de
vacances je pense que la découverte
d'une autre civilisation c'est un terme
qui peut être un peu exagéré merci
Jean-Marc Jancovici c'est toujours
stimulant de dialoguer avec vous au
micro de France Inter merci beaucoup